up next on Star Talk all about
psychedelics how are they being used
today to treat
PTSD what is the Fallen Mormon
study it when did they become illegal
and why what is the future of research
in these fields all that and more coming
up on Star
[Music]
Talk this is Star Talk Neil degrass
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
got with me my co-host Chuck Nice Chuck
hey hey hey Neil all right Chuck uh
professional comedian and actor so Chuck
our topic today yeah is psychedelics
whoa whoa and so we combed the landscape
of psychedelic
folk and we found Rick doblin Rick
doblin welcome to Star talk thank you
Neil thank you Chad I'm so glad to be
here with you today that I Rose to your
uh your combing process oh yeah the
thresholds you made the
cut so you're the president so Rick you
are the president and founder of the
multidisciplinary association for
psychedelic studies abbreviated
maps and you spent a whole
career studying psychedelics
is is all right all right well take I'll
accept the word studying psychedelics
for now uh well you don't have to accept
it because I'll say that part of
studying it obviously is having your own
experiences okay okay we'll get there
we'll see how that played out okay so
when I think of psychedelics and other
you know plus marijuana things that I'm
old enough to remember the 60s and70s
where these were just simply
illegal illegal and I don't ever
remember
any co coherent argument for why they
would be illegal yet alcohol is just
fine right and so so even as a child I
saw some inconsistencies in the laws and
legislations so it wasn't I was I wasn't
voting one way or another voting for it
or against it one way or another I just
saw an inconsistency between the two so
our psychedelics as we Define them in
your world still restricted and if
they're restricted then how do you work
with them
legally well first off I think we need
to say that the drug war and prohibition
has never really been about the reducing
drug abuse it's always been about
persecuting minorities and if you can go
throughout history from the 1880s or so
where the first drug laws were against
opium against the Chinese laborers who
came to build the railroads then um you
we had alcoh prohibition after that
ended disastrously shortly after that we
got marijuana prohibition that was
mostly used by Mexicans and
African-Americans um the Crackdown
against the 1960s against the hippies um
you know there there's a pretty famous
quote about um John Erman who was
Nixon's domestic policy adviser saying
that Nixon uh White House had two major
enemies one was the Civil Rights
Movement the other was the hippies and
right he said did we um um exaggerate
the risk of drugs yes so that that way
we could break up their meetings arrest
their leaders right and so it's always
clear that this drug war has never
really been primarily about reducing
drug abuse so interesting and I had not
I didn't put two and two together I had
I had a thread long enough I might have
seen what you just said with the Opium
going back to the Chinese laborers back
when we were building our railroads
right right are are you are you saying
that white people don't get high
is no if white people are in charge you
know I don't know they don't get
persecuted as much for getting high
right no I
got obvious thing there is the the
outrageous differences for a while
between penalties for crack cocaine
versus pudle cocaine yeah the outcomes
the legal outcomes of that have been
staggering
stagger you know and well so how do we
do our work it is possible to do medical
research with illegal drugs with FDA
approval and DEA approval so right we've
been able to do work um well basically
very quickly was that the control
Substances Act of 1970 which Nixon put
into place criminalized all the
psychedelics and also successfully wiped
out psychedelic research both in the
United States and around the world for
multiple decades wow massive cultural
amnesia
so there was a lot of research in the
60s with LSD and psilocybin for medical
applications and that was legal but you
know it kind of escaped to the streets
and just remind us about psilocybin that
that comes from what what is that
psilocybin is the main active ingredient
in psychedelic mushrooms mushrooms got
it okay mushrooms got it okay mescalin
comes from peyote or from San Pedro um
MDMA and LSD do not exactly appear in
nature in the same ways that there
there's precursors that then get chem
they come from God's
laboratory that's that's where they come
from well people have a romantic idea
exactly that if it's from nature somehow
or other it's good it's okay and if it's
it's not on this show we're more mature
yeah we're a little more and people
don't also don't realize that when
you're looking at how drugs interact
with your brain what you're really
looking at our neurological receptors
and connectors it's not about something
being natural and when we synthesize
that the only thing that we're doing is
recreating a substance that does the
same thing most of pharmacology is that
to be honest I tweeted not everything
natural is good for you and not
everything artificial is bad for you
right just
for created a fight now why should you
know people I can't you know but that's
thing to say not everything is natural
is good for you you know but then we
take those natural things and we
manipulate them so that they can be if
it weren't for snake venom you know how
much stuff snake venom actually helps us
with you know it's like Po there's a lot
of poisons that we turn into medicine so
well actually one of the most important
poisons are are um Venoms comes from the
Frog this Sonoran Desert frog and that's
5mo DMT which is the most powerful
psychedelic that we're aware of right
Rick have you been licking frogs lately
come on now that's what you do in the
laboratory I go for the
synthetics you go for the pill version
of it see I want to actually lick the
Frog I'm not gonna lie there's something
about it that you know so let's get back
to the permission back to you have to
you have to petition to study it to
obtain it without getting arrested and
then studied in the lab yeah so what
happened and um the controlled substance
Act of 1970 and the backlash against the
60s you know wiped out a whole field of
science for multiple decades but then in
1992 the FDA had a special advisory
committee meeting and they decided to
reopen the door to psychedelic research
and in a way that was a lot of pressure
from the AIDS Community because the ACT
up had um surrounded the FDA
headquarters and said that in the crisis
of AIDs that the FDA was being too slow
to approve drugs or even to permit
research because they were over them of
the Dallas Buyers Club yeah yes exactly
an important running theme of that that
the FDA uh now as a scientist you know I
we generally try to air on the side of
caution but when people's lives are at
stake you want to at least loosen that
up a bit so that you take a different
level risk and in a way that people
recognize and understand what you're
doing very much so so and they were
successful and it was shocking to the
FDA people that their whole uh building
was shut down and so the FDA created
What's called the pilot drug evaluation
staff no longer exists but it was to
create new ways to evaluate drugs and in
1992 they opened the door and they said
they would resume research with
psychedelics so so 92 would have been
the last year of bush Senor correct yes
yes so it did happen under Bush senior
and then but that really opened the door
to psychedelic research and so we had
had Maps I started in
1986 and similarly to psychedelics
having been medicines before they became
uh party drugs MDMA was a therapy drug
from the middle 70s to the early 80s
before it became more widely known as
ecstasy and used in a party setting and
so the FDA um had never reviewed it but
since it was legal there was a lot of
therapeutic use and then in 19 um 885
the DEA criminalized MDMA while we were
in the middle of suing them to keep it
legal as a medicine we won the lawsuit
but DEA ignored that criminalized it so
from 86 to ' 92 we had five different
protocols from Harvard Medical School
from um UC San Francisco with MD may all
reject it but 1992 was the key moment
where the FDA opened the door again to
psychedelic medicine so 31 years ago and
now we're in the midst of a Renaissance
of psychedelic research all over the
world where we have four or five times
as many studies going on now is at the
height of the 1960s wow awesome even
before it was criminalized yeah
I'm a little confused because you called
MDMA a
psychedelic and um as a person who has
done it I know that it has psychedelic
properties but I thought it was more
pro-social because it's you know
methylene deoxy methampetamine so I know
I don't think of methamphetamines as
psychedelics can you well let's back
let's back can you help me out wait wait
let me let me pre do preamble to that so
when I think of any kind of drugs that
people do part part of why they do it is
that it's altering your State of
Consciousness in some way so where's the
Line in the Sand between what cannabis
would do to your mind and what a
psychedelic would do to your mind well
if both of them are disrupting your
awareness of an objective reality right
and also hyperventilation do you have to
put it like
that you got put it like it's disrupting
your awareness of an objective reality
what is wrong with that sentence you got
you got a problem with that sentence can
it can it not be enhancing your
experience of an objective reality I
mean we'll get there we'll get there I
want to make sure we have the our
vocabulary is going the right places
here yes okay so rather than actually
talk about Altered States Of
Consciousness we use the words
non-ordinary State of Consciousness
because Al besides and we don't use word
hallucinogen either which is a
perjorative negative kind of thing it's
a delusion so psychedelic was invented
in the 50s by a man um named Humphrey
Osman in communication with Aldis Huxley
and they were trying to come up with
word for these LSD and psilocybin and
they didn't like the currently available
Words psychotomimetic which meant mimic
psychosis because it's more than that
and so psychedelic means mind
manifesting and that was um Humphrey
Osman was an early LSD researcher so I I
use the broad term mind manifesting to
bring out to the um from the unconscious
or from things that we haven't been
paying attention to into awareness so
that's why psychedelic for me is
something that you can have a
psychedelic experience with deep
breathing with holotropic breath work or
different kinds of breath work
techniques you can have it with uh MDMA
with psilocybin but MDMA is not like the
classic psychedelics so there are
classic psychedelics like LSD psilocybin
masculine um iasa you know that that
dissolve the ego dissolve the sense of
self and you sort of can can connect to
a larger sense of reality because our
brain is a filtering mechanism and so we
filter out a lot of information and
we're also organized on survival of the
organism but we often lose track of how
we're part of something much bigger so
psychedelic for me encompasses MD MMA
other people say oh MDMA should be
called an empathogen like to make
empathy yes oh empathogen interesting
interesting word EMP it it engenders
these great feelings of deep you know
emotional connection to people you feel
uh somewhat euphoric about being around
other people even people that you hate
you just like you all of a sudden you
just like man I have always loved you
okay well a good example is in octopuses
so there's a John's Hopkins
neuroscientist G Dolan by the way that's
the last sentence I would have ever
thought I heard a good example from an
octopus okay take us there go okay so
for those octop for those people that
have seen my octopus teacher that
documentary you know that octopuses are
solitary creatures around 600 million
years ago the human and octopus line
diverged but octopus is still process
serotonin and they have a whole
different kind of brain than humans and
so Ghoul at Hopkins wondered what
happens if you give MDMA to an octopus
and so Ms was more than happy to send
her MDMA to give to her octopuses what
happens is that o octopuses under the
influence of MDMA all of a sudden want
to hang out with other
octopuses whereas before they would kill
other octopuses they they don't want to
hang out unless it's Mating Season near
the end of their life
right so so what it means is though that
the pro-social effects of MDMA are
evolutionary conserved and
preverbal and so there are very deep in
the in the in the genetic code wow is
what you're saying yes very much so and
so that's there there also been studies
that g has done in mice with MDMA that
shows that they release oxytocin which
is the hormone of love and nursing
mothers and connection but then the
oxytocin oxytocin
stimulates synaptogenesis meaning new
synaptic connections are made right in
pro-social areas of the brain so that so
you're rewiring your brain to be more
loving and more caring by doing it
or well in part by doing it but then
also the important thing is the
integration and the work afterwards so
that there's the difference between
recreational use of drugs and
therapeutic use of drugs is recreational
drugs you're use you're just trying to
have fun while you're doing it therapy
you're really trying to change people's
Baseline and so what you're trying to do
is help them learn something and then
bring it back and practice it in a way
integrate it afterwards so Rick you're
saying that we're implying I think that
there are drugs that can build neuroc
connectors that
remain when you're no longer under the
influence of that drug and
therapeutically that could be in the in
the interest of the patient yes and not
only that though that these new neural
connections can be more easily created
sometimes for weeks after the experience
so this neuroscientist Gul Dolan at
Johns Hopkins what she's shown is that
the length of time that that you're in
the Psychedelic
experience influences how long
afterwards that this um she calls them
critical periods there's we we know that
children can learn language easier than
adults that they're in this critical
period there's other critical periods
for social learning and different things
and so this neuroplasticity of the brain
can extend for periods of time sometimes
weeks and weeks after the Psychedelic
experience and that's why we focus on
two parts in therapy it's the initial
experience that people have but then
it's the integration work that they do
to try to take what happened during the
experience itself and make it more part
of their Baseline to improve you know if
they've work through depression or work
through certain kind of traumas that you
can um anchor this in new neural
connection so I'd say one of the most uh
amazing things in terms of um
terminology has been that when we were
demonizing MDMA when it was criminalized
in ' 85 and from up until around early
2000 the whole term was
neurotoxicity that Brain Change is
inherently bad it's
neurotoxicity now we've turned that into
neuroplasticity because we see that
these outcomes in therapy settings can
be profound and they can be durable in
some cases we've done some studies where
we've looked at people um on average
three and a half years after MDMA and
some people up to seven years and on
average the results are durable so how
do we explain that I think it's in part
because the experience are can be so
profound but also because of this
neuroplasticity thanks to our partners
at overview for sponsoring this episode
and mostly for making me look so good
this right here is a high-end vest made
solely for space Enthusiast by a brand
named after the overview effect ever
think you hear that phrase as we all
know space gear is cool but typically
it's not something we'd wear in a
professional environment well the folks
at overview are looking to change just
that produced by some of the Premier
clothing manufacturers in the world this
vest is incredible it has suede edges
and it just might be one of the most
comfortable things I own if you want to
show people that space is something
you're passionate about but you want to
do it
discreetly this is the piece for you
they come come in black or dark blue
with their signature moonrise logo in
the corner now these are normally
$199 shipped but of course star talks
got you covered if you're interested in
checking them out head to where
overview.com and use code stalk at
checkout for 20% off that's wear
overview.com with your code Star Talk
for your 20% discount and then all you
have to do is slip it on and look good I
mean you're not going to look this good
but you're going to look
good and what does MDMA stand for MDMA
stands for methylene dioxy
methampetamine so I'll just say in 1953
the US so when we just say meth is that
what people refer to that's a that's
that's a whole another that's a whole
another another okay no yeah so so let
me say so in 53 the Army chemical
warfare service looking for mind control
drugs they tested eight drugs in animals
and on one side was methampetamine and
the other side was masculine from peyote
or from San Pedro and in the middle was
MDMA and they're all part of the
chemical family called
phenethylamines so of all the classic
psychedelics like LSD psilocybin MDMA is
closest to mesculin and so a good way to
understand MDMA is that it's like
methamphetamine in the sense that it
makes you alert it takes weigh your
appetite but it doesn't make you jittery
or you know the methamphetamine can make
you you know clean the room five times
stuff like that right but you can do
MDMA and be quiet and still but it's
alerting and it's like mesculin in the
sense but masculin does have this ego
dissolving properties and it's a certain
warmth but MDMA does not have the same
kind of ego dissolving properties that
you see in the classic psychedelics so
MDMA you could think of as kind of
halfway between masculine and
methamphetamine and it's all from the
same chemical family so you feel alert
and you feel good and you feel warm but
you don't want to walk to
Canada
exactly like because that's what methyl
do to you be like you know what we
should do guys we should walk to Canada
right now let's
go and actually well methamphetamine has
been used in war it makes sense because
one you can't you don't sleep so you
know you could just fight on and fight
on and fight on and two it makes you
highly paranoid which means you're apt
to be more violent and to respond to
things you know in in a in a way that
you you know without passivity so so in
recent years we've heard progress made
great progress made with psychedelics in
the treatment of
PTSD could you explain to me what's go
and what what's going on in the brain
and what role does the therapist play in
this presumably that matters at some
level that matters more than anything
else so what we talk about it is MDMA
assisted therapy so this idea that it's
really therapy that the MDMA helps be
more effective you can take MDMA you
could think of it like a tool you can
take MDMA and you can end up being worse
off if you're not in a supportive
situation the drug itself is not the
agent it's the therapy and the drug
makes the therapy more effective
so this is I I'd like this analog where
in my field we have telescopes that
bring us to the universe and microscopes
bring us to to cells and other
functionings in biology and these
psychedelics are are a way to probe the
Mind well Stan gr who's 92 the world's
leading LSD researcher has said exactly
what you just said he said psychedelics
are for the study of the Mind what the
Tes telescope is for astronomy and the
microscope is for um chemistry and
medicine I guess I was just quoting him
because I I I don't claim originality
with that but people always wondering
because I'm I'm asked all the time
what's more complex the human mind or
the universe and I always say the human
mind because we understand the
universe yeah you know I can plunk a I I
can plunk a Rover down in a in you know
in 100 square meter box on Mar
right and so uh to the extent that we
have access to the brain uh it feels
like we're still in our infancy but
these are very important points of
progress listening to both of you right
now it sounds to me like this you know
these substances are like a tilling of
the soil for the mind this is what this
neuroplasticity is and then the therapy
is where you get to go in and create
something new this this this fertile
ground now becomes this platform where
you can create something new where
neurons that you know fire together wire
together yeah yes yeah but if MDMA can
help help resolve
PTSD uh and but can't it also trigger
feelings of suicide so well yes again
I'm worried when two very opposite
effects can come out of some impetus
well again if it's in a therapeutic
context the suicidal feelings that that
from having people been traumatized or
being in despair you work with them and
then they're part of the healing process
so I just want to go back one step to
say that a lot of times people do not
understand that the telescope was
extremely controversial Galileo died
under house arrest father Bruno that was
an advocate was burned at the state by
the Inquisition so the tools that bring
out information that runs counter to the
sort of powers that be of the day the
tools themselves have been criminalized
and and have become controversial but
now we don't think of the telescope as
controversial so psychedelics are in
that same way their tools they brought
out things about our unconscious about
our sense of self that was somewhat
challenging to a lot of the the dominant
and your execution trial is
when we're speaking to you in the
basement of your prison C right not that
you'll care cuz you know you'll you'll
be you'll be on MDMA
it'll oh that blade feels so
good oh that blade just feels so nice on
my no they burn you it's a it was a
Christian Catholic thing so they burned
the steak on they burn that's right I
just give the
guillotine yeah well it's also it it
doesn't see I think that's a good J
that's a good thing people have this
wrong idea bunch of our therap our
patients have said I don't know why they
call this ecstasy it's not like you take
MDMA and everything's fine right Neil
you asked about the brain so MDMA
reduces activity in the amydala the fear
processing part of the brain MDMA
increases activity in the prefrontal
cortex where we think logically one of
the things about PTSD is you're
triggered by your reminders of these
traumas but but you don't have the the
time or the capacity to think carefully
is that sound really a bomb or is it
just you know a backfire or something
and then also MDMA increases
connectivity between we have to explain
to everyone under 30 what a car backfire
means please explain that yes
that's yes definitely yeah something
goes wrong with the engine it just sort
of makes a loud noise yeah no what
happens is some fuel gets into the
exhaust line that wasn't fully burned in
the piston and if a spark hits it it's a
pop and it sounds like a gunshot and
there's a hole
set of decades where people could not
distinguish a gunshot from a car
backfiring and yeah yeah yeah so so the
thing about PTSD is PTSD changes your
brain you have a hyperactive amydala
where you process fear you have
reduction of activity in the preed
cortex so you're not logically thinking
and evaluating and also with the
hippocampus where we put memories into
longterm storage there's diminished
activity MDMA does the opposite reduces
activity in the migala so the fearful
memories are not so overwhelming you're
prefontal cortex you're able to think
more logically and then the connectivity
between the amigdala and the hippocampus
means that we're able to take memories
in trauma that seem like they're always
happening the trauma is never really
fully in the past and so MDMA permits
these memories to be moved from sort of
foreground to background and placed in
people's past as part of their story
instead of the dominant active force in
their present interesting yeah yeah so I
had a little bit of PTSD dare I even use
that phrase for what I experienced um
after September 11th because I was four
blocks from the collapse of the towers
that entire morning was
continuous police sirens and and and um
a fire fire engine s continuous and as a
New Yorker these Sirens are just
normally
acoustic wallpaper right you don't even
notice if a siren goes by but it was
continuous and and plus it's it's now
was associated with for me with the
collapse of the towers watching people
fall from the towers this sort of thing
up until eight months afterwards if I
heard a siren anywhere I would just
tense up in my shoulders it would be
brief and and it was not you know
traumatic for me but it was there and I
would it was like an autonomic reaction
to it and it took the better part of a
year for it to fade now it doesn't
happen anymore and I I and forgive me
for even suggesting that's a PTSD no
that's a PTSD because compared with what
real military people experience I have
the same uh same reaction to Sirens but
it's because I'm a black man oh
that's so yeah yeah I know exactly how
you feel okay
well um yes so but Neil what what you're
talking about is that most people that
are traumatized over time they're
resilient and they're able to overcome
it but there's a population of people
which I count myself in that group yes
yes so so you're you were a sort of
acute stress disorder but it didn't
translate to post-traumatic stress
disorder which is chronic and enduring
for sometimes decades we actually had
someone in our study from Vietnam who
had PTSD almost half a century and was
still able to get better an American
serviceman from Vietnam yes
American yeah yeah so I I think that the
resilience is something that um a lot of
people don't have they they live under
constant stress they're they're so and
often there's we call it the archaeology
of trauma too people are often
traumatized at multiple stages in their
life particularly those people that have
childhood trauma are more vulnerable
when adult trauma happens to not being
resilient enough to get over it okay
then it becomes chronic and so that's
where the MDMA assisted therapy can come
into play because in that case it's like
open sores from childhood that would
never fully heal yes that that's a good
way to say it yes yes and so we are able
to try to um work with people with
severe chronic PTSD in a therapeutic
context so again you talked about
Suicidal Thoughts um people have um
taken MDMA in party settings and
remembered past trauma and not been able
to cope with it because they're out with
their friends they just want to have a
party these difficult experiences come
up they suppress it they don't want to
talk to their friends their friends
don't want to hear about it and then
they can be worth worse off for months
or years afterward so again that's why
we say and what we're telling the FDA
and and basically everybody through this
uh our discussion and others is that the
drugs are tools you you can have for
example a telescope that somebody could
look through and learn nothing if they
don't have the proper context and
understanding so the tools themselves
it's it's the fundamental problem with
the drug war is that we have invested
things with certain kind of properties
they're good things or bad things and
we've lost this idea that it's the
relationship that we have with it that
determines
it you're going to need an entire
College to teach therapist psychologist
psychiatrist how to use these drugs
because that I I don't think that goes
on in medical school or
in I I I don't it goes on in New York
City nightclubs baby there's no you know
I I don't remember seeing LSD 101 for
therapists you know so how do you how do
you turn the laboratory results into
action yes well for example on uh in the
next few days there's a two-day
conference at Harvard medical school
about psychedelics oh good
okay first first time in my life I ever
wanted to go to
Harvard actually the major schools of
Psychiatry around the country are
realizing that to attract young
psychiatric residents they have to teach
about psychedelics and so I think once
MDMA if it becomes approved by the FDA
which we hope may happen the middle of
2024 cybin I think will be approved
maybe near the end of 2025 2026
potentially only when these things are
really there for psychiatrists and
therapist to prescribe will will the
medical schools and schools of
psychology put it into their core oh I
get it so then it's just like any other
medicine it's it'll have a list of
Contra indications exactly how and when
you would use it what the risks are
because I presume the FDA for psilocybin
if you're targeting
2025 or 26 it's because they're right
now doing experiments yeah so Maps is
the leading U organization in in this
whole field if you say so yourself well
I I
uh let us say that let us say that so
wait wait wait wait wait wait I got you
here ready um yes so Rick what's the
leading I thought you were G to set them
up like you know you know the we hear
that you're the
leading I don't want to toot my own horn
but let me
say right that we on September 14th of
2023 we published the second of our
phase three studies the results of it in
nature medicine and in May of 2021 we
published the first of our phase three
studies and no other organization has
has published any results from any phase
three studies so so that's what I mean
we're the closest to FDA approval of any
psychedelic assistant therapy and just
to remind people not that I can recite
this verbatim but these different phase
studies as defined by the FDA relate to
uh how thoroughly investigated the the
effects are of the newly tested drug
right so so there's animal test on
animals for non-human animals and then
uh let a size of sample gets bigger and
bigger right and they look for for side
effects each each one is a little more
advanced in this is that correct with
that in mind how come you guys haven't
just tapped the millions of young people
in this country who are doing the
research for
you cuz believe me that research is
being done on zero in a daily basis
that's phase zero well exactly we we
have in some ways to look at the risk
profile so so the FDA will only approve
drugs Based on data gathered and FDA
approv protocols but you can look at the
risks by looking at people experimenting
on themselves so the national ins on
drug abuse funded now this was about 15
plus years ago but this was the critical
study we called it the Fallen Mormon
study it turns out there was a bunch of
people in Salt Lake City that had only
done ecstasy they had not done alcohol
or tobacco or marijuana or anything else
even coffee but they had done a whole
lot of ecstasy and so one of the the
concerns has been about the supposed
quote risks of neurotoxicity has to do
with neuropsychological performance so
the national on drug abuse um funded a
$1.8 million we did a $155,000 pilot
study and gathered some data and showed
that these this group of people these
Fallen Mormons really did exist and then
1.8 million came from naida to Harvard
to the mlan hospital where they did this
exhaustive study on the risks of
neurocognitive declines and they did
hardly showed any it was very reassuring
so there is some way where the safety
profile is benefited by the illegal use
of but but that data sort of as
foundational database for that yeah yeah
yes yeah there's over 5,000 papers right
now in Medline about the scientific peer
review journals about MDMA or ecstasy
there's Anor government just to clarify
for just to clarify the value of the
Fallen Mormons is you have confidence
that whatever was measured in their
intellectual abilities over that time
that did not decline there was no other
Force operating on it because they were
not drinking alcohol because Mormon
rules prevent that even caffeine so that
that was a pure experiment as
experiments go epidemiologically right
yes the only concern is was the drugs
that they were taking was the Ecstasy
that they were taking really pure
right it may have Mi with other things
but but in general that that was because
when we do MDMA and therapy we're
fundamentally different than the Pharma
companies working with ssris or other
things those are daily medications that
people take for months or years or
decades we're trying to and they usually
cover symptoms but they often don't get
to the root cause what we're trying to
do with psychedelic assisted therapy
with MDMA assisted therapy for PTSD is
to help people get to the root of the
problem and and work deeply and release
the emotions release the the the
memories like that and then through this
integration process that we talked about
during this neuroplasticity make it so
that they don't need MDMA anymore we're
not trying to get people to use MDMA on
a extended period of time we're trying
to do a few doses mixed with therapy to
make it so that the root causes have
been addressed how does Micro doing of
psychedelics fit into your whole
worldview here yeah well there have been
several studies of uh people micro doing
LSD and the the claim has been in
Silicon Valley and elsewhere that it can
in improve focus improve creativity
there there's been an incredible
interesting study with psilocybin um
called semantic priming and so what that
means is if I say day you say night if I
say sun you say Moon you know we have
these normal patterns but under the
influence of psilocybin when you prime
somebody with a word the word that they
come back with is from a wider range of
associations so you say day and I say
there is no
[Laughter]
God that would be a a good
example yeah okay thank you Chuck for
that for that therapeutic example there
yeah so so I think that there is this
thought with micro doing that it can
inove kind of creativity in this way
it's I would say unfortunately the
studies that have been done looking at
LSD for micro doing for creativity did
not distinguish it from
Placebo so whether it's something that
we can really scientifically demonstrate
or not maybe some of the claims were
maybe the measures weren't sensitive
enough but I think there's a small group
of people that would micro do for
depression anxiety for to give them
energy but in general my view is that
we're in favor of macro doing
we we don't want people to be dependent
on taking something on a daily basis for
depression anxiety PTSD any number of
Eating Disorders we'd rather do the Deep
work that gets to the root problem but
and that brings us back to the therapy
because cures it yeah you have to be you
have to have the therapy in order to
achieve those results all right so let's
let's go the other extreme here so we're
talked about therapeutic use of drugs
and this is what your whole
organization's been doing for 40 years
almost 40 years now yeah what about just
what we read about and hear about I I've
never done it but if you're fully
tripping yeah right and then you're
hallucinating and is there value to that
or is that totally recreational or
should that still be
outlawed well it definitely should not
be outlawed the drug war is completely
counterproductive it it's not helping in
any way and it is a tool of repression
and so so yes these things should
automatically be legal I I would say
that this idea that hallucinating so
this is where um words really matter and
so the hallucination as it is where it
is it's not real it's false it's a
delusion there's going to be a paper
coming out of Johns Hopkins and NYU
fairly soon and it took religious
leaders from different religious
traditions and administered them cocy it
and then had them discuss whether that
was um something that felt to them
whether they had sort of mystical
religious
experiences and so sometimes under the
influence of psychedelics people feel
that they're in touch with a deeper
reality that it's not a delusion just it
this began in 19 this whole line of
research began in 1962 at Harvard with
what's called The Good Friday experiment
and that was the first study to ever
look at do psychedelics can they produce
what's called a mystical experience and
there was I don't know if you known but
there's a fellow named Reverend Howard
Thurman was the um incredible Dynamic
African-American Minister he studied
with Gandhi and learned about
non-violent resistance and then he was
Martin Luther King's Mentor because
Martin Luther King got a PhD at Boston
University and Howard Thurman was his
mentor and Howard Thurman really helped
introduce nonviolence into the US Civil
Rights movement and so when Timothy liry
and Walter Panky who was a doctor and a
minister working on his PhD approached
Howard Thurman and they said we want to
study whether psilocybin can produce
these mystical experiences Howard
Thurman said sure I will do that because
he was very interested in the political
implications of this sense of connection
and he permitted This research to be
done on Good Friday in his Chapel when
he was giving a sermon and we have his
original sermon by the way up on our
Maps website during the Good Friday
experiment it's incredible and so it's
not um it doesn't feel to people like
quote a hallucination
like it's a delusion it feels that the
the brain is a reducing like like you
talked about how With Sirens you know in
New York you you just you don't hear
them anymore normally because they're
always the background our brain aldus
Huxley talked about our brain as a
reducing Val to eliminate those things
that are extraneous and focus on what we
think are the most important needs and
that when when you do a psychedelic a
classic psychedelic this reducing valve
is sort of weakened in its ability and
more things are happening so should this
should these things be legal yes will
there be problems that people have yes
but those problems I think can be
addressed in certain ways and the
problems of drug prohibition are even
worse but but I do want to say that this
paper coming out of the NYU and Johns
Hopkins about religious leaders taking
cybin from different religious
Traditions talks about how they they see
it's inevitable it's hard to put into
words but it feels to many of these
people to be a deeper truth and
something then that they want to put
into practice they become a little bit
less um how should I put it literal and
more
metaphorical more they become a little
bit more ecumenical so I I think these
experiences can have profound impacts on
people and have for thousands of years I
am a Scientist I very much care about
objective reality science did not
achieve maturity until we were able to
succe sucessfully either extend the
reach of our senses with tools um with
microscopes telescopes machines that
read uh or just completely replace our
senses with um with or invent things
that sense the world in ways we don't
even have senses to notice okay yes so
everything you've said in this
conversation either is there to help
someone who has who is is in need of
some repair in their brain okay through
anxiety
PTSD suicidal okay or to take a
spiritual person and have him feel more
spiritual in whatever way that manifests
yeah can we agree then that there's no
chem the brain barely works as it is it
barely works that's you know think about
think about um optical illusion books
right is the line bigger or smaller I
can't tell it's a simple drawing and
your brain can't is it in the page out
of the page okay so we now stir
chemicals into the
brain do you have any hope or
expectation that a day will come we're
doing
so gives me a more
acute understanding of objective reality
rather than subjective reality because
if that's the case we can give it to
everybody and then everybody is
connected to what's going on in this
world in ways that never happened before
here's the thing though what if if if
our brains work in a on a subjective
level which is what you just they work
on a subjective level yes then why would
these drugs actually help us to obtain
objectivity it seems like our brains are
set up for subjectivity so really
wouldn't it be can we better look at the
world
subjectively because because we're not
because we're not going to look at it
objectively we're just not well wait
well I what you just said there is there
people who've lost some connectivity to
the world and these are helping them get
to the Baseline of the brain that barely
works okay that's what I think you just
said in part so Rick what so so so talk
to me Rick get help me through this okay
well I I want to make an offer to you
that that there are opportunities
legally to try um
psilocybin that you might want to
explore at one time of your life to see
only if you have evidence that my
awareness of objective reality is better
than it was without it if it's going to
take me oh by the way by the way I'm not
denying that this could trigger a
creativity in the artist okay or you
know not that it always came out that
way because it's some really crappy
music written in the 60s that didn't
make it out of that decade written
completely under the influence okay um
so one of my favorite episodes of of
Family Guy is they were they were all
being hippies again and they all got
high the whole family and they performed
in the school uh talent show and they
have like flowers in their hair and
they're performing this Perfect songs
and then you see the audience's view of
them and they're slurring their speech
everything there's no they can't carry
the tune so that the self-perception is
great but so so I don't I'm not arguing
against the creative dimension of this
just the objective Dimension okay so
let's just go to Carrie mullus for a
second so Carrie Mullis won the Nobel
Prize for the PCR and how do you do all
of this uh the polymerase chain reaction
he said that he got some of his ideas
for his invention of that when he was
under the influence of LSD and and
marijuana so it can promote creativity
but then you have to check it so not all
the ideas that you get under the
influence of psychedelics are um are
good ones or accurate ones but some of
them can indeed Carl Sean Carl Sean was
a you know daily marijuana smoker was
very much say he was pothead you can say
it he was a pothead yeah yeah yeah he
was a pothead so I think that there
has did not know this big time B time I
know I liked
him you didn't know why you like him so
much I didn't know why I liked him so
much but now I
know I think you have this idea of can
you have an idea under a non-ordinary
state of consciousness and have it
actually be an advance to better
understanding yes that's that's the
that's the summarizing what it took me
five minutes to say to you yes yeah so
so the answer is is yes some ideas that
you can get under non-ordinary states
are insight so what what what Carrie
Mullis said is he was able to dance on
the molecule level to see how things put
together and then he was able to get an
inspiration and then only when you check
it out can you decide is that quote
objective reality or okay got you so
what we've done here is Cherry Picked
the one person for which this was true
so what you would need to do is get uh
get all the Nobel Prize winners and do
the experiment right it sounds to me
what Rick is saying in that instance is
that it's it's turning the chessboard
you know what I mean that's that's
really what's happening it's the answers
are there they're still within you but
when you turn the chessboard you're like
oh wait I'm I didn't see that and you
know so that that's that's what I'm I'm
Gambit of you there okay very good yes
but I think that there's also insight
into yourself so you you know in a sense
that that yeah but that's not helpful
for the universe no I I I'm not denying
that I don't need insight into myself to
know what the big bang was doing you
know at a millisecond after the moment
so okay so let's go to Einstein one of
Einstein's statements was imagination is
more important than
knowledge right okay so this imagination
you could say testing out hypotheses
under the non-ordinary states of
Consciousness that that you can there
was a study actually at Stanford in the
60s that used masculine and LSD for
people that had objective problems with
their business with science with
different things and gave them um a
psychedelic experience to help them try
to resolve some of these problems so Jim
fatan who's did this research is also
one of the main advocates for and stud
students of micro doing so I think that
there are situations where yeah turning
the chessboard looking at things in a
different way you know being at the
molecular level to dance on the
molecules to figure out how to do the
PCR okay so so I'm saying I you know you
can have ideas on a toilet right in a
hot tub walking in the woods so if this
is just one way that could happen that's
useful I'm not an early adopter of
anything so I will wait until there are
more experiments done with
objectively brilliant creative people
creative in their objectivity of the
world and if you start showing me
research papers on that then I'll
consider it um but until then anytime
I've anytime I've sat next to someone on
any kind of chemical influence in their
brain it is the least productive
conversations I've ever had about re
they're fun it's like you know uh can
beer laugh you know can I you can have
conversations but I'm so
as a
scientist uh you would be um following
the scientific Traditions to explore to
see whether this seems valuable to you I
agree I just say I'm not a first adopter
that's all I
am I am I am an early early adopter I
will show up before the session
begins with with with with the utmost uh
enthusiasm
Rick we got to end it there this has
been a delight highly informative uh and
I feel like we're witnessing the birth
of an entire
new uh uh portal of access into the
human mind that can only uh when
properly shepherded such Say by yourself
and your organization that only good
could come of that so first
congratulations for staying with it and
taking taking civilization to a new
place thank you I just want to add that
that because because of the work with
veterans even though most of the people
with PTSD are women we've been able to
get bipartisan support so we have
managed to take psychedelics out of the
culture wars and I think that we and we
are doing a lot of work inside the
Veterans Administration and important
addition very important fact to add to
this conversation because we we're
living in an area where everything is
partisan if you can if you can if you
can bridge that I think nothing's in
your way and I would also add that seels
have been used for thousands of years so
you're a long way away from being an
early
[Laughter]
adapter fair enough right there okay
Rick thanks for being on the program
Chuck always a pleasure all right Neil
degrass Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking
[Music]
up